†CCUS 21 - The Civil War Part 2
Hi, I’m John Green; this is Crash Course
U.S. history and today we return to...wait,
what are we talking about today, Stan?
Ah, the Civil War!
I can tell because Lincoln’s here.
But this week we’re not gonna talk about
casualty counts or battles or its generals
with their heroic and probably fictional dying
declarations.
Mr. Green, Mr. Green, wait did that one guy
not really say “Honeybun how do I look in
the face?” because that was the best part
of this whole class.
Jeb Stewart did say that, Me from the Past,
but it probably wasn’t his last words, but
anyway today we’re going to try to focus
on what’s really important.
In the end the really vital stuff isn’t,
like, Pickett’s Charge or Lee saying “It
is well that war is so terrible - otherwise
we would grow too fond of it” or the surrender
at the Appomattox Court House.
That stuff matters and I don’t want to deny
it, but the Civil War and the way we remember
it is still shaping the world today, and that’s
what I want to focus on, because it’s the
stuff that might actually change the way you
think about your own life in your own country,
whether it’s the United States or the Green
Parts of Not America.
intro
So let’s start with one of the big questions
historians still ask about the Civil War:
Did Lincoln free the slaves?
The answer, as with so much here on Crashcourse
is yes … and also no.
Let’s go straight to the Thought Bubble
today.
So Lincoln’s reputation as the Great Emancipator
rests largely on his Emancipation Proclamation,
an executive order which went into effect
on January 1, 1863.
This order ostensibly freed all the slaves
in territory currently rebelling against the
United States, i.e. in areas where the U.S.
government had no authority to free slaves.
This is rather like the United States announcing
that from here on out, North Korea will be
ruled by Lady Gaga.
Sure, it’s a great idea, but it’s not
really your jurisdiction.
In areas where the U.S. did have the authority
to free slaves, the border states and some
of the areas of the Confederacy that had been
effectively conquered and occupied by federal
troops, those slaves were NOT freed.
So Lincoln didn’t free the slaves that he
actually had the power to free.
Many historians argue that, in fact, slaves
freed themselves.
How?
By running away to union lines and becoming
“contrabands.”
Because this was a time of war and slaves
were seen as a valuable resource to the enemy,
when they escaped and sought refuge with Union
troops, Union commanders wouldn’t give them
back, despite fugitive slave laws still being
on the books.
So many slaves escaped, the argument goes,
that Lincoln was basically forced to issue
the Emancipation Proclamation, because until
he did so, those contraband slaves were still
technically property of their Southern masters,
and the Union generals were breaking American
laws by not returning them.
The Emancipation Proclamation then had the
added bonus of encouraging more slaves to
come over to the Union lines, many of whom
joined the army, which eventually included
about 180,000 former slaves and free black
men.
Thanks, Thought Bubble.
So Lincoln may also have issued the proclamation
in order to shift the focus of the war from
union to slavery to prevent the British from
recognizing the Confederacy.
Arguably the Confederacy’s best chance to
win the Civil War was to get some kind of
foreign patron, and Britain was the likeliest
choice as it was very dependent on Confederate
textiles.
But as you’ll remember from all those people
going to Canada, Britain had already abolished
slavery and it was the historic source of
abolitionist sentiment, and so it was very
shrewd of Lincoln to make the war about slavery.
Off-topic, but if I may put on my world historian
hat for a moment.
Thank you, Stan.
The fact that the British did not recognize
the South had profound effects on the whole
world, because it meant that the British shifted
their focus to Egypt and India as sources
of cotton for their textile mills.
All that noted, I think Lincoln does deserve
some credit for freeing the slaves for two
reasons.
First, he pushed for the Thirteenth amendment
which actually ended slavery in the United
States.
And perhaps more importantly, he continued
the war to its conclusion and demanded that
the end of slavery and the return of the Southern
states to the Union be conditions for peace.
This may seem obvious today, but in 1864 it
wasn’t.
In fact, there were numerous calls in the
North for an end to the war that would allow
the South to exist as a separate country and
leave slavery intact.
Now, of course, the rest of world history
indicates that at some point slavery would
have ended, but by prosecuting the war to
its end, Lincoln brought about slavery’s
end sooner.
But the Civil War didn’t just end slavery.
If it had gone differently, Me from the Past
might have been annoying teachers in a different
country from the one in which I now live.
I might’ve need a passport to visit my parents
in North Carolina and slavery might have survived
for decades--Brazil didn’t fully abolish
slavery until 1888.
And the south would be covered in green as
part of Not-America.
Or, the north, depending on where you’re
watching this video, I guess.
And, the people who lived through the Civil
War knew it was momentous.
In his famous Gettysburg Address, Abraham
Lincoln fostered the idea that the Civil War
was a kind of second American Revolution,
or at least a culmination and reaffirmation
of the first one.
“From these honored dead we take increased
devotion to that cause for which they gave
the last full measure of devotion--that we
here highly resolve that these dead shall
not have died in vain—that this nation,
under God, shall have a new birth of freedom—and
that government of the people, by the people,
for the people, shall not perish from the
earth.”
We tried to hire Daniel Day-Lewis for that,
but he was unavailable.
That phrase “new birth” of freedom had
religious significance as well because it
was, like, the 19th century equivalent to
“born again.”
So, the Civil War was the first modern war
in terms of its scale and its destruction.
Like, others have waged war on civilians to
break the spirit of their enemies (STAN!
Mongoltage OPPORTUNITY!)
mongoltage
But new technologies made this one of the
most destructive wars yet recorded.
And, yes, I know the Taiping rebellion took
more lives, and in terms of percentage of
population killed, the contemporaneous war
in Paraguay was worse, but bear with me.
Rifles, and toward the end of the Civil War,
machine guns shifted the way that people fight.
It became easier to defend a line, so cavalry
charges and huge waves of attacks started
to be just slaughtery although it would take
World War I for the rest of the world to figure
that out.
And the incredible numbers of dead and wounded
really changed Americans’ relationship with
death itself.
Like, the Gettysburg address was given to
dedicate a new national cemetery, and the
Civil War helped to create a culture of meditation
on mortality itself that led to cemeteries
replacing churchyards as the final resting
places for most Americans.
And the sight of slaughter and the sheer weight
of it had profound existential effects on
a generation of American intellectuals from
Walt Whitman and Oliver Wendell Holmes.
Oh, it’s time for the Mystery Document?
The rules here are simple.
I guess the Mystery Document and usually I
am shocked.
Oh my gosh, today’s Mystery Document is
on an iPad!
This appears to be a photograph of wounded
soldiers in hospital.
I’m gonna go ahead and call it as being
by Mathew Brady.
What?
I already got it?
But I didn’t get to say the name...
Oh, it’s called Wounded Soldiers in Hospital.
Thank you for an easy one, Stan.
So, Mathew Brady was a prolific photographer
during the Civil War, although, like a lot
of prolific people, he often took credit for
work done by his employees.
And Brady really changed the way that people
thought about war.
He and his staff created some 10,000 images
during the Civil War.
And it was the first time that an event had
been photographically documented so thoroughly.
By the way, lest you think that the unreliability
of images began with Photoshop, many of Brady’s
photographs were staged.
He would move bodies, sometimes soldiers were
apparently told to act dead.
But of course, at the time, photographs felt
inherently authentic and written accounts
of battles could now be accompanied by actual
images of the fighting and its aftermath.
But, perhaps the most important impact of
the Civil War was the new nation that it created.
Like, the American Civil War fits right in
with the global phenomenon of nation-building
that was happening.
Soon we would have places on the map like
Italy and Germany, and older places like Greece
would be re-born as nation states.
And then all of these places would be known
to Americans as Not-America.
But, by the way, congratulations to Italy
on the recent election of their 732nd Prime
Minister in just 180 years of existing.
By far, the most successful of these new nation
states were the ones that embraced industrialization
and modern ideas of organization and centralized
government.
Northern victory in the Civil War meant the
United States would follow the path that the
North laid down.
It would become an industrial rather than
agrarian nation, with a national government
pre-eminent over those of individual states.
It would become a nation.
And its not a coincidence that over the course
of the 19th century, people stopped pluralizing
the United States; they stopped saying, “The
United States are a great place to live,”
and began saying, “The United States is
a great place to live.”
The Civil War helped singularize what had
been until then a plural nation.
And Abraham Lincoln was the first president
to truly expand the power of the executive.
He ordered blockades and suspended habeas
corpus, in addition to emancipating the slaves.
But the Republican dominated congress played
a role in this federalization too.
Congress passed the Homestead Act in 1862
that encouraged settlement of the west by
basically giving away land to anyone who had
$18 and was willing to live on it and farm
it for five years.
Downside: you have to live in Oklahoma.
Unless of course you’re an American Indian
in which case, downside: you don’t get to
live in Oklahoma anymore.
You may be wondering, how were we able to
sell all of this land so cheap?
It’s because we stole it!
Meanwhile, the Morrill Land Grant Act financed
colleges to offer training in new scientific
agricultural techniques.
The Department of Agriculture was created
to generate statistics and share best practices
in farming.
Congress also helped unify the country with
the massive land grants in the Pacific Railway
Act of 1862.
And during the war the Lincoln administration
gave away 158 million acres to railroads to
tie the nation together.
Get it?
Tie?
Railroad ties?
The nation toge-?
I’ll take my coat and go.
Plus, as you may have noticed, wars are expensive.
And in order to finance the Civil War, Congress
passed the first progressive income tax in
American history, as well as floating huge
bond issues to the public.
And when that wasn’t enough, the administration
began printing federal money on green paper
called “greenbacks.”
These, along with notes issued by banks under
the National Bank Act of 1863 became the first
national currency in the United States.
Altogether, the total cost of the war for
the Union was $6.7 billion.
Interestingly, if in 1860 the federal government
had purchased every slave and granted a 40-acre
farm to each family, the total cost would
have been $3.1 billion.
But a) it would have been hard to get that
bill through Congress, and b) at the time
the federal government had no way to raise
that kind of money.
The federal government also actively promoted
the industrial economy that was to become
dominant in the United States after the war.
In fact, industrialization was so healthy
that visitors to cities in the North during
the Civil War would have been hard pressed
to notice that they were even in a war.
So, ultimately, the Civil War was a victory
for Alexander Hamilton’s federalist vision
of what America should be.
I mean, Thomas Jefferson could never have
imagined the United States that emerged from
the Civil War, a government that supported
an army of a million men, carried a $2.5 billion
national debt, distributed public lands, printed
a national currency, and collected an array
of internal taxes.
It sounds like Britain!
So, the Civil War wasn’t just a victory
of North over South or of freedom over slavery.
It created the nation that the United States
of America has become.
Thanks for watching.
I’ll see you next week.
Crash Course is produced and directed by Stan
Muller.
Our script supervisor is Meredith Danko.
Too far!
Our associate producer is Danica Johnson.
The show is written by my high school history
teacher, Raoul Meyer, and myself.
And our graphics team is Thought Café.
Every week, there’s a new caption for the
Libertage.
You can suggest some in comments where you
can also ask questions about today’s video
that will be answered by our team of historians.
Thank you for watching and as we say in my
hometown, don’t forget to be awesome.
Civil War 2 -